[Musique]
distingue des campements de sans-abris
a Philadelphie les transports en commun
sont frappés de plein fouet par la crise
des opioïdes et l'itinérant on y
consomme de la drogue au grand jour et
chaque soir des centaines de personnes
n'y trouvent refuge
en patrouille sur les plateformes de
métro parce que les gens y consomment de
la drogue ils tombent sur les rails cela
arrive régulièrement et c'est très
dangereux dit-elle
internet ça raconte une fait partie des
travailleurs sociaux mandatés par septa
l'agence de transport régional pour
éloigner les sans-abris des stations de
métro de Philadelphie
nous l'accompagnons dans le quartier
Kensington l'un des plus pauvres de la
ville et une plaque tournante du trafic
de stupéfiants
il n'y a pas si longtemps dit-elle ce
coin de rue devant cette station de
métro était bon des gens qui campaient
et consommaient de la drogue pendant la
pandémie la situation s'est détériorée
un point tel qu'une des stations du
quartier a même dû être fermé c'est là
l'agence de transport a décidé de
changer de stratégie oui
de réduire de 35%. le nombre de
sans-abris dans le réseau depuis son
lancement il y a deux ans
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été dirigés
vers d'autres ressources comme des
refuges et des maisons de transition
il dit que c'était à dépenser 25000
dollars cet hiver pour réserver 500 lits
dans des refuges afin de loger les
personnes déplacées
mais les efforts de septa sont loin de
tout régler selon ce travailleur de rue
ce soir là il rend visite à une dizaine
de personnes installées dans une station
de métro du centre-ville
pendant l'hiver ils sont parfois une
centaine s'y installer il n'y a pas de
toilette et les excréments s'accumulent
dans les escaliers racontent-ils
s'ils ont déjà vu les travailleurs
sociaux de septa mais les deux hommes
assis par terre ne semble pas savoir de
quoi il parle
avec son organisme Tom Cruise parcourt
les rues de la ville plusieurs soirs par
semaine mais il dit que cette terre ne
l'a jamais consulté
selon lui la solution à l'itinérance
dans le métro c'est d'abord ré avant
tout la construction de logements
abordable
l'agence de transport dit que son rôle
n'est pas d'éradiqué l'itinérance mais
plutôt de s'assurer que ces transports
en commun sont sécuritaires elle
reconnaît aussi les limites de son
programme elle aimerait déployer 14
équipes de travailleurs sociaux mais
avec la pénurie de personnel elle n'en
n'a que trois ce jour-là
petites victoires
comme cette ancienne sans-abri qu'elle a
réussi à sortir de la drogue
même si elle sait que la bataille pour
sécuriser le métro de Philadelphie est
loin d'être gagné
Sandra nous liams Radio-Canada
Philadelphie